[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new stranger things
season 5 video so amazing news the
duffer brothers finally announced that
they are doing stranger things season
five so i'll explain what's going on
what they've said about the villains
what they said about the russians during
season four about hopper coming back
and about what's going on with their
schedule and when we'd actually see
season five episodes because they're
still in the middle of shooting season 4
right now
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the easter egg
videos i'll be doing
stranger things season 4 videos as we
learn more about that too
so we'll just start with the big stuff
and number these as we go along just to
stay organized
but the duffer brothers were doing a big
interview they started by talking about
the russians as villains in the cold war
themes and how they originally set that
up during season one
in how some of their early story lines
that they didn't really think too much
about
actually turned into much bigger things
for season 4 and season 5.
they talked about how they originally
set the russians up it's just a small
nugget as part of 11's training you see
them using 11 to try and spy on the
russians as part of this cold war
program
you learn that the russians are trying
to do the same thing trying to create
their own
espers like 11 to spy on the americans
during those tests is when she lost
control of her abilities and ripped a
hole in the fabric of our dimension
creating the gateway through which the
mind flare was able to enter in various
stages
season to season from the upside down so
a lot of those early concepts that they
set up with the russians versus the
americans in this cold war program
turned into their big season four story
line because now we're literally
in russia one of their taglines when
they release the last big stranger
things season 4 trailer was from russia
with love like literally they're going
to russia now because hopper stuck there
the russians were big villains during
season 3 but the duffer brothers were
talking about how the show is
positioning them as the new main
villains whereas in season 3 the duffer
brothers just considered them
side villains and billy was intended to
be the main villain at least through the
mind flayer because the mind flare was
controlling everyone like literal
meat puppets infecting them with that
goo they actually said that whole billy
arc during season three was supposed to
happen during season two but daiquiri
montgomery's audition tape just blew
them away so much that they wanted to
turn billy into a much bigger character
so that's why that all played out during
season three
they also implied that they haven't gone
back to start shooting season four again
yet because of the virus they got shut
down in production just a couple weeks
after they've started filming season
four episodes so they still have a long
way to go
on those and it sounds like they won't
be filming again till this fall they
just say that they're excited to go back
and film so
obviously they're not filming right now
the way they talk about it they already
know what their ending for the show is
going to be and they know when it's
going to happen
and they've been using this virus
shutdown to sort of plot that out and
figure out how much more time they need
to tell that so i suppose it's possible
that they could go beyond season five
but the way they talked about it in
previous years is that they had a
relatively short story planned and they
weren't planning on stretching it out
for seven or eight seasons or anything
like that
so right now i'm just assuming that they
stop at season five and that's the final
season
but because of the schedule on season 4
being delayed it sounds like they won't
start filming season 5 episodes until
spring next year or summer but netflix
did talk earlier about possibly trying
to film stranger things season 4
and season 5 back to back but when they
were talking about that they were mostly
referencing the issues that they had
with the kids getting too old too fast
aging up
otherwise they'd have to have some big
time jump at the beginning of season
five
now it's more about the virus delaying
everything but i don't think the kids
getting older is that big of a deal like
look at eleven during season one
now look at millie bobby brown now in
real life as we speak
most of the younger people who watch the
show for 11 for millie bobby brown and
the kids probably don't even pay
attention to details like that they're
more concerned with the plot
and what the characters are actually
doing but the duffers didn't give away
any huge spoilers as to who the main
villain of season 5 would be outside of
them finally fridging the mind flayer
permanently
because as at the end of season 3
they've still only defeated the avatar
meat puppet it was controlling through
the dimensional rift from the upside
down
operating this giant beast by remote
control and all the people it infected
with the goo
including billy for most of the season
that was what his big sacrifice was at
the end of the season 11 was able to
enter his mind
and free him from the control of the
mind flayer by showing him his mother
and his happy memories of his past
then he was able to quote unquote throw
himself on the grenade before it could
kill 11 of the others
and even though we know that hopper is
coming back because he shows up in the
season 4 trailer in siberia russia
laying all that track billy is still
currently supposed to be dead
so if daiquiri montgomery comes back it
would have to be as a memory of billy in
eleven's head or a mental projection of
the mind player
but within the world of the show billy's
physical body is dead as is alexis
so press f in the chat to pay respects
right now the season 4 replacement for
billy in terms of just
main villain for the story arc outside
of the mind player is going to be tom
blasia's character from game of thrones
it's really hard to pronounce his last
name so i'm probably messing it up but
he played jack and hagar
on that series a badass assassin
faceless person
so he definitely has a type the season 4
trailer just makes it seem like he is
the boss or the administrator of this
russian prison gang that hopper is a
part
of just a stone cold killer and he's
definitely a big level up in terms of
human villains from billy
but in terms of season 5 villains and
twists that the show hasn't used yet and
things that it's set up previously
ideas that it hasn't paid off there's
the whole concept of russian espers like
eleven
like during season two we met eleven's
sister just another person that was part
of the americans program but it was
implied that the russians had their own
version of this program
they didn't really explain what the
russians want with the upside down
during season three but i think it's all
just part of that cold war narrative
that they set up during season one
they want to weaponize it in a bunch of
different ways and use the upside down
like a fast pass system
like we see them laying this railway
here anything that exists
on the regular planet earth in this
dimension also exists in the upside down
but they also have that white demogorgon
that they have captive at the end of
season three
they probably hope to control their own
army of demogorgons and demo dogs
harvested from the upside down
but it's not really clear if they're
aware of what the mind player is
doing it sounds like because they're
teasing going back into the upside down
during season four that they'll address
that in some way
like they do reopen a portal to the
upside down but the mind player takes
advantage of it and because you have all
the russians 11 and the whole team
together
the mind player comes for 11 and the
russians get caught in the crossfire
because up to this point it doesn't seem
like the mind flayer really cares about
what the russians are doing
just expect it to be way crazier way
grosser and way bigger and for them to
all die horribly than the people during
season
3 including jack and hagar's character
here usually the only time they don't
kill off villains like if he survives to
season 5
is when they want to do a big billy
twist and turn them into a much bigger
villain in the next season
but like the duffers say they already
know what the final ending of the series
is going to be and what else could that
be
but them finally defeating the mind
player for good and then 11
getting to live a normal life with
hopper i know everyone has theories
about how the show is going to end and
one of the other main characters is
going to wind up dying
there's always tragedy every season but
i do think that the show
wants to give eleven a version of a
happy ending that she saw for herself
even if it's not exactly the way she
expects it to be like they won't have a
complete downer ending for the show
but the other big things that we know
about season four so far is that they
will have an extra episode it'll be nine
episodes total they'll be tweeted out
all these scripts here in their nine
different scripts meaning nine different
episodes
we know that episode one is titled the
hellfire club which is a big british
reference and a marvel comic book
reference for the x-men team
in the show it might just be what the
group calls itself as they get older and
embark on their mission to save hopper
and even though 11 seemingly lost her
powers at the end of season 3
she's probably just having some trauma
issues and has some sort of mental block
that was erected when she
thought that hopper died just the trauma
from that experience
just sort of cut her off from her
abilities temporarily
but since they don't want to drag their
feet too much at the beginning of the
season
early prediction at the end of season 4
episode 1 after moping around
all summer thinking about hopper being
dead she kind of gets her powers back
and senses him on the other side of the
world and realizes that he's still alive
and then they start to rally the group
to find a way to save him there has to
be some reason
that they find out that he's still alive
and then go try to save him
just in terms of big historical cultural
80s references because the show trades
on 80s jokes and references so much
because we're going to russia at this
time my big theory is is that they're
going to use chernobyl in the meltdown
to explain the season 4 finale in
another big disaster
involving the mind player but because of
all the christmas themes that they're
setting up in these teasers they might
wind up dropping season 4 episodes
around the holidays in 2021 like the end
of 2021 and they probably won't be able
to get season 5 episodes out at least
until
summer 2022 the next year but like i
said it sounds like they're gonna try
and shoot
season four in season five back to back
but the netflix stranger things accounts
are all really active
all the time so they'll be dropping
teasers for season four stuff for the
rest of the year so anytime they drop
new footage or a big teaser for season
four of course i'll do a video about it
let me know in the comments what are you
most excited about if you have any big
questions
while you wait for everything click here
to re-watch that season 4 trailer a
billion more times
and click here to learn about what just
happened with the new avatar the last
airbender netflix series that they're
making right now
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]